all right what's going on guys this is
rob and i forgot
that hulk number two was coming out two
weeks after hulk number one now after
this it's only coming out every month so
we'll have to wait like a month before
we cover the next issue i know it sucks
one of the things a lot of you guys have
voice to concern about is that sometimes
it's hard to keep track of stories so
what i'm gonna do is i'm actually just
gonna kind of create playlists for the
individual stories that we're doing so
they're super easy to follow we'll
probably end up with a million playlists
but there's no such thing as too many
playlists on youtube so for those of you
guys who are following devil's reign
you'll actually find a link to the
playlist in that video which right now
only has one video and then for this one
uh you'll find a link to the playlist uh
both for this individual story arc and
this video will also be added into the
main playlist for the incredible hulk so
that'll make it easier to follow along
having said that so in the first video
what we kind of talked about and what we
ran over here was really the change that
was going on with the incredible hulk
this idea that what banner had done in
the aftermath of like everything that al
ewing had done which was just a
ridiculously amazing story which we
still need to release a full story for
for immortal hulk um that what's
happened here is banner has basically
weaponized the incredible hulk in so far
that he basically turned him into a ship
because the incredible hulk is so
incredibly durable and so powerful he
can survive in almost any environment
and one of the things that was
established in jason aaron's run is that
the incredible hulk's physiology can
actually adapt to an environment so he
wasn't able to breathe underwater until
he was
and so what this means is that with
banner basically controlling the mind of
the incredible hulk and the incredible
hulk's rage being used as quote unquote
the engine that drives the ship that
he's basically able to do almost
anything he wants to and so far is
executing plants we don't really know
what this plan is what we do know is
that banner basically seized control of
basically celestial tech and then in
turn traveled into the multiverse now
the funny thing about this is that as
soon as he leaves his universe he comes
across a group that's referred to as the
alternate universe timeline hazard
operations response and intervention
team with some other word that starts
with a y it's authority this looks like
authority from dc comics those guys who
don't know that is the authority is
actually a group that operates
essentially in the multiverse but they
they well they serve different purposes
but they're a wild storm team uh we
haven't really talked about them and
maybe we should we haven't really done
much in the way of wildstorm but this is
hilarious because at the end of the day
he just plows through
[Laughter]
i mean none of these guys really have a
chance but it is kind of a funny thing
to see i mean tell me this ship in the
background does not look like the ship
of the authority from wildstorm they're
basically a pastiche right many of them
are not exactly those characters they're
basically a pastiche but when it comes
to the multiverse this is one of the
things i want to talk about we i like to
reiterate this every so often for people
who are either new or who have been here
for a while and need a bit of a
refresher there are a lot of teams that
patrol the multiverse for different
reasons like the exiles travel from one
universe to the other just basically
solving problems and we should cover the
original like not really the original
but like the exiles run uh that
basically went into what was basically
house of m and all that kind of stuff
did like the world tour storyline and
all that we should probably cover that
because the exiles are like the most
underappreciated but more most amazing
team in marvel comics like literally
it's just a team that travels to
alternate realities all their like every
one of their stories was awesome there
was never a boring story in the exiles
but nonetheless these guys are
obliterated pretty quickly
the other thing behind this is that
banner is basically asleep at the wheel
and it kind of makes sense right i mean
it's a pretty exhausting situation to be
in controlling a giant green rage
monster and then you know sitting him
into space a lot's happened over the
course of the day a lot's happened over
the course of the day so once banners
starts to wake up what you actually end
up finding out here is they're being
targeted and the reason why is because
there's somebody out there or something
out there that's trying to get their
hands on the hulk for reasons we don't
necessarily know we simply know that
they are but again this is the nature of
using the incredible hulk's rage as an
engine system that where this really we
could call it kind of a physical tractor
beam is trying to pull the the
incredible hulk in that banner amps his
rage up right as a means to just kind of
keep the or at least push the incredible
hulk to higher levels think of this as
something akin to like nos in a car
except you can regulate how much nos you
basically allow in that car and you
basically have it just increasing in
power forever right is is kind of the
big difference here but again like
monsters are basically introduced that's
set upon the incredible hulk one of
which is fenfang fume uh spoilers have
you guys played the guardians of the
galaxy game yet dude that game is
amazing i just finished it like a couple
days ago dude that game is amazing
fenfang fume looked awesome in that game
when they when they're like we need to
go find fen fang fume i was like yes
i really can't wait to see this but the
thing behind this is that again these
are just monsters and the incredible
hulk in what's essentially his his
almost like infantile form his savage
form just sees them as a credible threat
and attacks them that's one of the
benefits that banners kind of waiting
for when it comes to the incredible hulk
is the incredible hulk has not figured
out this is an illusion now this is one
of the big differences between what
donnie cates is doing and what al ewing
is doing that in a lot of ways al ewing
depicted the intelligence of the
immortal hulk or at least his ability to
understand his surroundings as being on
par with banner right i mean the
immortal hulk was not as intelligent as
banner right it wasn't one of those
things where he's like practicing
science and things like that certainly
not on the same level the banner was but
he was certainly a lot more cognizant of
what was going on around him right he
was able to understand what was taking
place in a more nuanced way than what
savage hulk is able to do now whether or
not this means the immortal hulk slash
devil hulk persona is gone forever or is
temporarily just kind of retreated it's
something that only time will tell right
we'll just kind of have to wait and and
watch as donnie case's run progress to
find out how this happens but regardless
what the immortal hulk's anger being
amped up more and more at the end of the
day banners told that the origin of this
entity is unknown but according to their
sensors they're being scanned and when
it turns out they're being scanned for
gamma radiation the initial response of
banner is it's the avengers right like
they're trying to find him or they have
found him and they're basically trying
to bring this guy back right they're
trying to reel him back into the
universe because the reality is he's not
supposed to be out there right like he
he overpowered the avengers in order to
get to this and so following that you
basically have him of course taking out
finn fang foom and you know the the
incredible hulk destroys these forces or
whatever and so banner needs more rage
and so as a really great throwback he
basically amps him up and has a giant
version of wolverine appear here now on
the surface you would think that if what
banner wanted to do was to maximize the
rage of the hulk that he would somehow
find a way to unlock the world breaker
hulk rage level right to make him you
know as angry as he's as he's ever been
but there's a couple reasons for why we
can surmise this is not really happening
the first is that to go from just hulk
who's kind of chill and relaxed or at
least is you know kind of minimally
angry we can call him that until like
world breaker hulk could possibly just
destroy his form right like i mean
destroy the the engine so to speak right
the other part of this is that given the
fact that the the world breaker hulk
form is essentially a more cognizant and
intelligent version of savage hulk that
what this would mean is that it would
figure out it's all an illusion right
like world breaker hulk would figure out
what's going on and then basically just
stop right and just just cease to fight
and just kind of maybe revert back to a
base form and call it a day there's a
few different reasons for why we can
discern that's not necessarily happening
the other cool thing here is that this
being a throwback is to the old
wolverine first appearance when he
fought the incredible hulk this is how
he looked right this is this is how
wolverine looked back in the day not
only that as most of you guys know uh
the incredible hulk and wolverine have
had some ridiculously good fights
especially with that animated movie
right hulk versus and it's like
wolverine and thor you guys remember
that movie that movie was awesome i'm
gonna watch that movie as soon as i
finish with this video but it was a it
was a great movie right it was it was a
great thing i absolutely loved it uh but
there's been some great battles here
right and there's a lot of i wouldn't
say animosity but wolverine kind of
represents this being that's very
difficult for the incredible hulk to
take out and so the incredible hulk's
rage just kind of keeps going and going
and going but as the fight breaks on or
continues on between wolverine and uh
and and the incredible hulk the hulk's
not getting as angry as he needs to be
the engines themselves are also critical
so it's almost as though the engines
kind of match what the hulk is going
through now you do get some cool moments
right where like giant wolverine goes
you know goes to stab the immortal hulk
and his claws get stuck in the ground
and hulk rips out one of wolverine's
claws which is awesome it's just
ridiculously cool to see but the the
this kind of disembodied betty ross
right who almost seems to be a voice in
banner's head to a degree seemingly his
conscience kind of chimes in and is like
you're pushing the incredible hulk too
far like if you keep on doing this
either he's gonna break he's gonna shut
down and he's basically like that that
persona is gonna be destroyed possibly
replaced with another or simply just
losing your ability to power this engine
entirely or everything is gonna go belly
up the crazy thing about this is that if
this version of the incredible hulk is
seemingly defeated slash destroyed that
what would happen is banner would revert
back into his human form right like
remember all this is essentially taking
place in the mindscape right like this
ship that banner's sitting in is the
brain of the incredible hulk and the
incredible hulk himself is just his
persona fighting all these enemies that
banners making him see that appear to be
real but actually aren't right that's
one thing to keep in mind this is not
happening on some planet somewhere right
that's not really what's going on here
but that if this version of the
incredible hulk is defeated or destroyed
that the incredible hulk will revert
back into his human form and banner
cannot withstand the rigors of the
multiverse in his current form right
like as a human being he cannot
withstand that he would basically be
destroyed and so that's why there's a
bit of desperation here that's why
there's a bit of a desire to to kind of
push the incredible hulk more and more
and find some way to get past this
ultimately though the incredible hulk
succumbs to this this kind of tractor
system that's pulling him in and there's
no conceivable way for them to find a
way out and so essentially once they're
pulled back in here or into this
particular location they crash land in
what basically looks like a cave with a
kind of stasis field that's keeping the
incredible hulk in place now we're not
really given the details of the stasis
field and in reality we don't really
need them but i would surmise that given
how it's technology-based it's likely
one of those things where it basically
reinforces the strength of the
incredible hulk so for every punch he
doles out that level of strength is
amplified two times over by the shield
so basically the shield is always more
durable than the incredible hulk is
right like the incredible hulk strength
works against him and being able to try
to break out of this thing the crazy
thing is that there's just this kind of
guy out there right like this this
person out there that you can't really
make out that says that like after all
these years they finally caught it right
they finally caught this person and
where banner doesn't know what's going
on right like who in the hell are you
like what what in the heck is happening
here the the person kind of chimes in
and says wow you're wildly different
from all the rest of them right you can
speak you can reason and you're in
control like this is kind of weird like
don't be afraid i mean you no harm my
name is dr bruce banner this looks like
bruce banner from an alternate reality
now try as i might this is not an
existing version of bruce banner that
i'm familiar with and i've searched high
and low this is not a version of banner
that we've seen before so it's not like
the incredible hoax landed in like the
house of m universe and this is banner
in that universe this is a seemingly a
reality that we've never seen before
which makes me
wildly excited to see what donnie kate
is gonna do here but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end thank you all for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace